under their watch
how on earth does he sleep at night with
so much blood on his filthy privileged
hands
well tonight that was how parliament
reacted but we're also going to try and
find out how it's going down with voters
so we'll be hearing from conservative
supporters a mother whose young son was
fined for breaching covert rules plus
we'll be talking to our viewers panel is
there so we'll be talking to the panel
too we'll also have some really top
guests on the show including the
northern ireland secretary brandon lewis
labour's shadow culture secretary lucy
powell and much more besides that is all
coming up on
the take
[Music]
hello good evening well sue grey says
that senior leadership at the center of
government must bear responsibility for
the partying and drinking culture in
number 10 that existed at the height of
the pandemic she says that people will
be dismayed at the behaviour and had the
right to expect better her report says
there was fighting people being sick and
unacceptable treatment of security in
cleaning staff well boris johnson's
apologized repeatedly and said that he
was humbled but he also said it was time
to move on well it was a long-awaited
and explosive day in westminster let's
have a look at what happened
it's been published sugree's report into
parties at number 10 and whitehall has
now been published and then look at this
the event lasted a number of hours there
was excessive alcohol consumption by
some individuals one individual was sick
there was a minor altercation between
two other individuals there you have it
there was essentially a fight in the
heart of whitehall because of excessive
alcohol consumption
adam's prime minister's questions
for those who wish to leave
[Laughter]
as we come to the statement prime
minister when i said i came to this
house and said in all sincerity that the
rules and guidance have been followed
at all times it was what i believed to
be true
i would like to correct
the record
to take this opportunity
not in any sense to absolve myself of
responsibility
which i take and have always taken i mr
speaker i i'm humbled and i have learned
a lesson
they pretend that the prime minister has
somehow been exonerated
as if the fact that he only broke the
law once is worthy of praise
the truth is
they set the bar for his conduct lower
than a snake's belly
with a a war in europe
with an economic crisis
with the challenges this country faces
is it not really true
that it is now time to turn a page i
made my point and my position very clear
to the prime minister he does not have
my support
can he think of any other prime minister
who'd have allowed such a culture of
indiscipline to take place under their
watch and if it did
would they not have resigned in this
farce of a parliamentary system it's now
all down to tory mps and there are not
many left here for them to grow a
backbone and out this moral vacuum of a
prime minister would he spare them the
trouble and resign
[Applause]
[Music]
no mr speaker
well that is what happened today in
parliament and on tonight's show we're
also going to be trying to be working
out just how much danger boris johnson
still faces especially with voters well
first on the program i spoke to the
northern ireland secretary to get his
response to the report
thank you very much for being on the
program today uh mr lewis
late night parties people getting so
drunk that they're spilling wine around
the room they're throwing up they're
getting into fights
and this was going on in downing street
while ordinary people were following the
rules that those in number 10 had set
should the prime minister now resign
no the prime ministers take
responsibility for everything that was
happening number 10 and he has
apologized for that i think he's set
that out properly and rightly so
obviously these were things that were
happening over a two-year period much of
which obviously some of these events it
turns out looking at the report the
prime minister wasn't even in number 10
at the time but he has already taken on
board some of what was set out in
sugray's interim report and as she's
noted the report today has already been
implementing the changes that were
needed to be seen at number 10 to change
that culture and change the structure
you say that changes have been made and
i'll be honest i'm struggling to see
exactly what changes and who is taking
responsibility for it the prime minister
isn't resigning the head of the civil
service simon case isn't resigning
martin reynolds the man who invited 200
people to a party and then emailed to
say we seem to got away with it he seems
to be being moved to another plum job in
the civil service so how is this taking
responsibility
well first of all the prime minister has
publicly taken responsibility of this he
made that point uh very specifically uh
on the floor of the house of commons as
well just by staying apologize ability
doesn't mean you're not getting away
from them
well
but he has taken responsibility he has
said he accepts the findings of the
reports he's accepted the findings of
the the police's uh investigations as
well and he has changed the team at
number ten there's been a very very big
change in the team at number 10. not
least of all the chief of staff
obviously as you say other people have
left number 10 and different people have
come in there has been a changing
structure then actually sue's great
report uh it today itself outlines that
she acknowledges that there has been
change that she thinks is delivering on
what she's setting out and then
just to
just to come back in the head of the
civil service simon case isn't resigning
martin reynolds the man who sent out an
email to 200 people is being moved to
another job we understand the prime
minister isn't resigning there may be a
change in personnel in number 10 but it
seems to be completely unrelated to who
actually should be taking responsibility
to some of what's going on
well there has been as you say change at
number 10 so quite substantial change at
number 10 in the team that have come in
there now and are working through and
getting on with the job of working for
the country and delivering for people
across the country on a whole range of
issues and that's where the focus um has
been and as i say over the i think it is
right that the the sugro report itself
recommended that there was change there
was clearly a need for some cultural
change there and some of the things in
the report today do make difficult
reading um and that's why i think it was
right the prime minister set out as he
did on the floor of the house today
you tweeted to say the pm has apologized
unreservedly and is already implementing
the recommendations for change we must
now get on and deliver for the british
public as they rightly expect
what is your evidence that the british
people do want you to just get on with
things and deliver rather than taking
responsibility and for the prime
minister to resign
well there's a a number of things come
together i think look first of all we
have got an unprecedented situation in
this country we're still recovering from
the pressures of covid and what that's
done to our economy and our wider
society obviously the fallout from the
war in ukraine and dealing with those
issues but have also had a knock-on
effect in terms of food prices and also
energy prices where we're seeing this
global pressure on energy prices this
global battle with inflation that is
having an impact on people across the
country i think these are issues that
people want the government to be focused
on and delivering on what they elected
us to do in 2019 but i go further than
that and say to you over the last
few weeks obviously we've had low
collections one of the things i've seen
when i've been out and about talking to
people in those elections and actually
talk to people outside of election time
as well as i do with my own constituents
is people wanting to see us focused on
the issues that are affecting their
everyday lives and working particularly
at the moment to ensure that we get
some structure around what is happening
in ukraine because people do care about
what's happening ukraine a sovereign
democratic country and that they believe
we're doing the right thing by
supporting the people of ukraine and the
ukrainian government but also dealing
with those issues such as the pressures
on cost of living that they're seeing
through the pressures on inflation
particularly the challenges around
energy that people are seeing and that's
what i'm getting in my mailbox is what i
get when i talk to people on doorsteps
that they want to see us dealing with
those core issues that's what they
elected us to do and that's what they
want to see us deliver on of course you
know i'm not saying that people don't
care about all those things but people
can also care about integrity in public
life and whether or not parties were
going on in number 10 while everyone
else was following the rules and the
reason i asked for evidence is because
the evidence that i'm seeing you know a
snap pole by yougov showing three and
five britons say boris johnson should
resign compared to just 30 percent who
say he should stay in the result in the
role has the prime minister saved his
job but lost the next general election
for you
i'd say so i didn't catch all of that
but i think i i got enough of the back
end of your question there to know what
you're saying look as we all know from
uh years of experiencing yourself as a
journalist in politics and myself as a
politician is polls are a snapshot in
time uh the reality is the the votes
that count of what we see in a
generation like i've said before quite
openly i think that boris johnson is the
right man to be leading our country i
think he will lead the conservative
party into the next general election and
i do think he will win it and i think
he'll do that because people will see
that when they elected us in 2019 they
did that on a manifesto that we will
have delivered on and we will be
delivering on the things people elected
us to do but also look at those big
decisions that the prime minister's had
to make whether it's through the
decisions around covet all the decisions
uh with the support for ukraine and i
think people will see over the months
ahead as we supported people through
kobe we're determined to do everything
we can to support people through that
global challenge of inflation and i
think getting those big decisions right
another reason why people will put their
confidence in the prime minister again
to see us through the next general
election as well
now there's one thing i am i'll be
honest a little bit puzzled about today
sue gray didn't investigate the alleged
party in the prime minister's flat that
happened on the 13th of november 2020.
now this is when five aides joined the
prime minister's wife at 6 pm the prime
minister then joined at 8 p.m food and
alcohol were available and then it went
on into the evening
in your view was that breaking the rules
oh well the the police have looked at
this and sue gray as uh well you've seen
my sister grace reports for greater than
the police have not fined uh
investigating the entities penalty
notice that he has already outlined so
clearly well the police who looked at
everything and the police and sue grey
had access to far more uh details and
documentation than either you or i have
had and i respect the decisions they've
come to and i think we've got a and i
have absolute confidence in the police
to have done a thorough job as they
always do so
i'm not talking about the police view
that those rules were not broken in that
one i'm not talking about the police
investigation i'm talking about the
sugre investigation and i'm just really
puzzled as to why she didn't investigate
the one thing the one event that could
have caused the most problems for the
prime minister the alleged party that
took place inside his own flat now we
know boris johnson had a meeting with
sue gray before the publication of this
report instigated by number 10.
did they discuss at all whether or not
the flat party would be investigated
well as sue grows put in her report
obviously she's been she's had access to
all the information that she's asked for
and and has had information she said no
paul that she had not saw where people
have come forward with information
obviously the police had the ability to
look at anything and everything they
wanted to look at they said they have
clearly only issued one fixed penalty
notice to the prime minister as he has
outlined um and he has dealt with that
look as i say i don't know the details
of private meetings what i can say is
somebody who has worked with sue gray
both when she was dealing with uh ethics
and probity in the cabinet office and in
her
role here in northern ireland and her
role now
in the department looking at issues
around the union sue gray is an
independently minded very very focused
professional civil servant and she will
have done whatever she feels was
necessary to produce report that she
thinks is right i don't think anybody
could question either her
professionalism or independence and i
trust the judgment that she has come to
and i think she's come and written a
report that does make difficult reading
places i think that's why it's right
that the prime minister outlined as i
said today not only his apology but has
taken the action that was recommended in
her interim report as well in that
meeting between the prime minister and
sue gray
is it correct that he suggested that she
could drop the report i i wasn't in a
meeting between the promises of grace
i'm not a comment on a meeting i wasn't
in i think the reality is sue grey's
report is out it's published a report i
don't believe for one moment the prime
minister would have interviewed in any
way in the report he has been very clear
i have to say the conversation i've seen
him outline both publicly and and and
i'm sorry let me just finish sophie
promises always very clear he wanted to
see these reports come through both sue
gray's report and the police
investigation come to its completion so
that people would have the full facts
out there to be able to draw their own
conclusions of him to be able to outline
and answer those points as he has done
both with the interim report with sue
gray the fixed penalty notice and that
final report and the statement he's
given today i'll be honest i feel like
i'm struggling to get the full facts of
everything that went on
do you know you say you don't know what
happened between the prime minister and
sue grey at that meeting have you not
asked the question have you not tried to
find out because it does feel you know
if this is a meeting set up by number 10
uh ahead of the publication no no sophia
i can answer very directly no i haven't
no no no no sophie it's very simple no i
haven't because i have to having work
both with the prime minister who i know
what here where his focus is on the
issues that affect people across the
country those domestic issues people
want the prime minister dealing with
around the economy and around those
international challenges that we're
facing and actually have as i say having
worked with sue gray on a range of
issues over the years i have absolute
respect for sue gray's independence
sugree will not be
somebody who shies away from taking
tough decisions and giving tough
messages to people when she needs to and
i think she's proven that for her career
and with the report today
okay so you you're very upfront and
honest full credit to say you haven't
asked what went on in that meeting
between the prime minister and sue gray
is that because really you don't
necessarily want to know the answer
because if you perhaps didn't know the
answer it would be a lot more difficult
to come on programs like this and defend
the prime minister's conduct
look sophie i'm always happy to come on
your program in any situation i've come
and talked to you about a whole range of
issues and challenges over the years and
no that's not the reason at all it's as
i just outlined you look i know the
prime minister i work with the prime
minister i know sue graham i've worked
with sue grey in a number of different
jobs in government over the years and
i've i had no question or doubt
whatsoever that sue gray would put out
the report that she wanted to put out
with no fear or favor to do the right
thing she is a very professional civil
servant and she is somebody who will
always speak truth to power i've
experienced that i've seen her do that
and it's why she's such a talented civil
servant okay as you say um you have come
on a programme my program over the years
defending uh boris johnson defending
theresa may as well when you're working
under her definitely one of these people
who comes on to you know give the
defensive of the government so putting
that aside i just want to talk to you as
a person for a minute what would you say
to the people in britain many of whom
made huge huge sacrifices during the
pandemic some of them who lost loved
ones and they weren't even allowed to
see them in hospital when they were ill
or when they were in care homes what
would you say to them when they look at
the report
they look at what was going on in number
10. no that's a very fair question
what would you say
no it's a it's a
it's a very fair question and obviously
i have spoken to people who have been in
that situation both people i know and uh
through through work as well and no i
absolutely understand that the upset the
anger the frustration people have of
what they
could see was going on and what was
happening at number 10 why it's not
acceptable it's why i think it was right
that the prime minister took those
actions obviously the number 10 is a is
not just a it's a place of work but it's
also a home and it's a it's one of those
places you know sophia that uh the the
space in there is used across number 10
consistently but that's no excuse for
particularly as i say some of the
difficult things the report today and
one of the comments in there i think the
prime minister raised on the floor of
the house today as well around how some
of the staff have been spoken to by
other people it's just not acceptable
and that's why it is right the promise
is very clear about that apology both to
people generally across the country and
to those affected by this um situation
both in terms of how they've been
treated and dealt with in number 10 and
the perception that has created across
the country so i do understand that but
that doesn't move away from the reality
that i know and having worked as a
member of the cabinet through carved
conversations we've been having in the
work i've seen the prime minister
focused on whether it's widely for the
uk or here in northern ireland his focus
has always been on doing the right thing
to deliver for people across the country
and and that's why i think he has got
those big decisions right brandon louis
thank you very much for being on the
program today
you're very welcome thank you
brandon lewis uh they're saying the
prime minister has apologized change has
happened in number 10 and now the
country wants them to get on with the
business of government you're watching
the take you are live here in
westminster with us up next we're going
to be talking to labour's lucy powell to
get her take on sue grey report
[Music]
hello welcome back live to westminster
you're watching the take well we just
heard the government's take from uh
brandon lewis but it was a little bit
uncomfortable for the labour front
pension at times too because kierstama
was attacked of course boris johnson
over the su grey report but the pm was
able to retalk that kirsten was himself
under investigation by the police and
should resign well let's get labour's
take now we're joined by the
shadow secretary of state for digital
culture media and sport lucy powell who
joins us now and thanks for being with
us um what is your reaction to see
grey's report well i mean it's it's
very revealing isn't it the industrial
scale partying that was happening at
downing street the lack of judgment the
poor leadership the fact that these
things were allowed to go ahead with
great frequency and that they were
sanctioned in in effect and the sue grey
report makes clear that that book really
should stop with the prime minister and
the political leadership of downing
street but we heard from the prime
minister today that while he says
he takes responsibility
he's not owning any responsibility at
all because he's not
taking any action himself or recognizing
that he himself is at fault it seemed to
be
everybody else's fault but his own the
secret report it obviously does
it obviously you know really condemn a
lot of what went on in number ten but at
the same time it does feel like it stops
short of calling for boris johnson to
resign if you like and she also
says in her report in her conclusions
that she's pleased that progress is
being made in addressing the issues i
raised we heard brandon lewis saying
that there have been changes of
personnel in downing streets so
do you accept that sue grey appears to
be at least partially satisfied the the
government's listening well look at the
end of the day sue grey although she's a
woman of great integrity i know sue and
of course she is and she did an
independent inquiry she is nonetheless a
civil servant and she makes that clear
in her report as well that it's not for
her
to issue disciplinary action or
sanctions it is for the political
leadership of number 10 downing street
i.e the prime minister to then take
steps against those who are responsible
but she does say that she's pleased
progress is being made well some
progress is being made but she also says
that this was an issue of leadership of
judgment
and of political leadership and that
junior staff and others uh often only
took part in these events because they
were sanctioned by the prime minister
himself because he was at them and you
know that's why he's got to take
responsibility uh for for this matter
and also because he lied to parliament
he came to parliament and he said no
such uh parties took place uh nothing uh
happened and all the rules were followed
and that clearly
is now not the case i mean that's why he
really does need to resign and take
responsibility he argues that he said
that in good faith that he didn't
believe that rules were broken and he
also points to the fact that the police
have only fined him for the one single
event and the other of it the other
events that he's alleged to have taken
part in the police actually said that no
rules were broken on his part well he
has got a fine that means he did uh
break the law that's what that means he
broke the law
quite clearly and i think that is a
resignation offence he broke the law in
number 10 downing street where there
were 126 fines issued if that had been
a restaurant a nightclub a school or a
hospital during the pandemic it would
have been shut down by the authorities
for that level of uh rule breaking and
events uh happening and he says he he
thought that it was within the
guidelines i'm really sorry i mean he's
either
misleading us all and lying which i
believe is the case or he's incredibly
stupid um and you know if he's
incredibly stupid then he's not fit to
be prime minister either and you know i
think the bigger issue here is that
all the while the months and months
we've been uh talking about this issue
and i know your viewers along with
everybody else will on one level being
fed up
of hearing about this whole sorry affair
people's bills have been going through
the roof and the cost of living is
soaring and people are facing real
hardship and challenges and the
government hasn't been able to focus on
these big issues facing the country
because they are at disarray and they
you know they're dysfunctional there's a
problem though isn't there i'm just
taking a step back today
there's a problem because kirsten was
also of course being investigated by
police
for an alleged breach of covert rules
and that makes it very very easy for
boris johnson to throw that right back
at him doesn't it i don't think so
because kirstenberg
unlike boris johnson has said he would
take the ultimate responsibility were he
found to have break and broken the law
and he said that if he is given a fine
which he uh firmly believes he won't be
because this was uh clearly was a a work
occasion and a work uh break uh to have
a takeaway with only work colleagues in
a small environment there away from home
but that if he is found to have broken
the law then he would resign and that
sets him
massively apart from the prime minister
we are in a situation now aren't we
where it appears more likely that
kierstarma could end up resigning over
partygate than boris johnson well i
don't know that it appears more likely
well it doesn't feel like boris
johnson's about to resign well no that's
because he won't ever do the honourable
thing and he won't do the right thing
and he won't he's not someone who will
take responsibility for his own so it
does actually like it's more likely that
kidama could lose his job over this then
doesn't it well i don't think it's more
likely because i don't think kirst
armour has broken the rules but
obviously i think it's very unlikely
that this particular prime minister
will take responsibility for his own
actions breaking the law in number 10
having parties on an industrial scale
when we couldn't all go to people's
funerals we were having christmas on
zoom uh you know we're missing birthdays
missing loved ones missing those really
important times in life and the prime
minister stood up today in parliament
and seemed to suggest that he thought it
was okay because uh this was a
well-deserving colleague who who
deserved a good toast and a send-off uh
as a leaving party well i'm sure that
many people watching this program feel
like their close loved ones deserved a
good send-off for dying during covid and
they weren't uh able to do that and that
is absolutely appalling and i felt the
prime minister today really had quite a
tin ear about this whole situation he
seemed
to sort of bluster his way through
not accepting any responsibility it does
feel um you know as you say that it
looks unlikely that boris johnson is
going to lose his job at least
imminently over this
given that you know three and five
voters according to hugo i think he
should resign
electorally is that quite a good thing
for labour
well
i don't i don't think it's a good thing
for the country and i don't think it's a
good thing for politics
actually electorally do you think it
might be a good thing for labour well
it's not a good thing for the
conservative party so in that sense you
know maybe so but actually i'm not
really interested in that to be honest
i'm interested in uh as having a
government that's able to govern and
lead and deal with the very real crisis
that people are facing today which this
government isn't able to do we can't
wait for a general election to solve
this cost of living crisis we need the
government to take action now when we
need them to take it on a scale and at a
pace that is consummate with the crisis
that we are facing and they're just not
doing that well we may hear a bit more
on that of course because we are going
to get a statement from the chancellor
uh tomorrow lucy powell thank you very
much for being on the program this
evening lucy powell uh there well
pretty clear what labour thinks uh but
what about voters well we went to to the
all-important conservative heartland of
tiverton in devon where there is very
soon to be a by-election that's after
the conservative mp neil parish resigned
after watching porn in the commons to
try and find out what they thought of it
all
russia trying to take over threatening
nuclear
destruction do you think that's far more
important than a few drinks and a bit of
cake
really let's be fair
he's not stupid forget it let him get on
with his life let him get on with the
job he should be doing there's more
serious things going on in the world i
don't care if he had a crisp and a glass
of wine how many people can say heart
hand on heart that they didn't break
just by having somebody in to have a
drink bit annoyed
yeah because like couldn't see my mum we
had to facetime and
it was hard
really hard wouldn't it
we'll find out exactly what voters and
timberton think in a few weeks time when
we've got that by-election but in the
meantime we can try and work out a bit
more about where we are tonight with our
deputy political editor uh sam coats who
joins us now sam i have to level with
you you know we've texted an awful lot
of conservative mps uh today and a lot
of them keeping their powder dry
where do you think the prime minister is
at
the irony there sophie is actually i
think today's report came out at the
really
better end for boris johnson than it
could have done here's why in her final
report sue gray said the senior
leadership at the center both political
and official must bear responsibility
for this culture which she sets out of
the parties all the activities that you
mentioned at the top but she also gave
everybody in the conservative benches in
government a massive wiggle room which
is what she doesn't do is specify
how boris johnson in particular set the
culture in a way that was so loose which
created so much unacceptable behavior
there is nothing in her report that
suggests that he instigated was aware of
most of the events that we have been
reading about today and that is a
massive wiggle room and i watched
brandon lewis jump through it in his
interview uh with you this evening it's
also created an enormous problem really
for the labour party
um how did they respond in this
environment
where they can't they haven't been given
anything by sue gray with which to sort
of beat boris johnson having taken that
enormous gamble that kierstahler took to
promise to resign himself and to call
for boris johnson to resign now
that's fallen flag doesn't look right
now that he's going anywhere so where
does that leave the opposition parties
it's interesting isn't it um because it
does feel um as though the one event
the flat alleged party hasn't been
looked at by sue grey yet and i can't
really work out why not
so uh the explanation for sue gray as to
why she didn't go into the details of
this event where uh boris johnson was
there there was food and there was wine
there was a number of special advisors
he's that the police looked at it and
they decided not to issue any fines and
therefore she decided not to go in to it
any further now the thing is there's no
automatic reason why if one is the case
the other should automatically follow
why if the police didn't find it
couldn't sue gray uh actually look at
this in any more detail we don't know
there are reports i'm sure you've heard
as well i've certainly heard them that
people in the number 10 building could
hear the dancing the jumping up and down
on the floors to abba at that event but
no that remains a mystery even though it
was one that was considered most
sensitive inside number 10 so that's a
mystery the other mystery of course is
what happened at that conversation
between sue gray and boris johnson that
we revealed on friday
and whether or not boris johnson did
indicate that he was um curious as to
what sue gray would have to say in the
event that the police concluded were
there any hints perhaps there wasn't any
necessity to go into the flat party for
instance interesting stuff sam thank you
very much indeed and as some uh was
saying that it does certainly feel
as though boris johnson isn't going
anywhere imminently you're watching the
take we are live
in westminster for you this evening but
up next we are going to try and find out
what the public think
after the aftermath of that crucial
report could be the most important thing
of all
[Music]
hello welcome back live to westminster
you are watching the take well time now
to delve a little bit deeper deeper into
the details of sue grey's report now our
deputy political editor sam cope has
been going through it all
after six months of waiting 37 pages sue
gray's story of what went on in
westminster over 11 critical months of
the pandemic the picture clear while the
country was locked down and banned from
socializing parts of whitehall partied
hard
there are numerous examples of terrible
behavior in whitehall at the height of
the pandemic let's trot through some of
the worst examples such as this event
now this was in june 2020 an event
attended not only by the cabinet
secretary but also his deputy who was
the ethics chief who brought her own
karaoke machine sue gray writes the
event lasted for a number of hours there
was excessive alcohol consumption by
some individuals one individual was sick
there was a minor altercation between
two other individuals so there was a
fight in whitehall at the height of the
pandemic because of drunkenness or let's
look at christmas that year now there
were three different events on one day
in the lead up to christmas two of which
took place in downing street sue gray
wright a cleaner who attended the room
in downing street the next morning noted
that there had been red wine spilled on
one wall and on a number of boxes a
photocopy of paper worth saying in this
report by the way that there are
examples apparently of people inside
number 10 being rude to cleaners and
other staff after some of these events
which have pulled many on opposition
benches
wild behavior of various forms and
plenty in government acknowledging in
private they were breaking the rules
the best way to illustrate that they
knew what they were doing was wrong was
to examine the bring your own booze
event synonymous i think with partygate
look at this ahead of that event lee
kane who was a director of
communications emailed martin reynolds
the top official number 10 who organized
it and said this
a 200 odd person invitation for drinks
in the garden of number 10 is somewhat
of a comms risk a pr risk in the current
environment lee kang goes on to say that
he warned martin reynolds in person so
to dominic cummings who says he gave a
warning as well but the warnings were
ignored the event went ahead boris
johnson was there for 30 minutes 30 to
40 people turned up and in the end the
police fined many of those who attended
yet in the weeks after it took place you
can see this a media adviser messaged
martin reynolds about a story inquiry
and he replied well that's a complete
non-story but better than the focusing
than focusing on our drinks which we
seem to have got away with
bad behavior and cleared delight at
having got away with it but the question
hanging over sugray's investigation has
always been what did boris johnson know
and how much blame should he get there's
nothing in the report that suggests that
boris johnson was involved in organizing
or even knew about many of the parties
in this report danny street will also be
relieved that there's nothing in here
incriminating about allegations of a
party in the downing street flat sugray
started investigating it but when the
metropolitan police decided that they
weren't going to actually any fixed
penalty notices to do with it she
concluded it was not appropriate or
proportionate to do so so what are the
conclusions well sue gray says the
senior leadership at the center both
political and official must bear
responsibility for this culture but she
suggests it's already being fixed she
made some suggestions in january and i
am pleased progress is being made in
addressing the issues i raise that
suggests that there are no specific
changes she wants to see down in the
street will be very relieved by that
conclusion
painful yes but in the circumstances the
best number 10 could hope for with
little new information to transform the
debate and broad brush conclusions that
don't point the finger at the prime
minister is it now over
sam coats sky news westminster
sam kate says is it over well maybe
according to the politicians but of
course the most important verdict is
from voters so i'm really keen actually
to see what our viewers panel made of it
all uh they're weighted they're
politically balanced uh so let's have a
little look at what they make of the
actions today uh hello everyone good to
see you all now just before i get to uh
talking to you all individually i'd like
to see a bit of a show of hands
if you think boris johnson should resign
after the publication of that report i
want you to put your hand in the air say
put your hand up if you think boris
johnson should resign
makes
pretty balanced one two three four five
people who say that they think he should
resign
and if you don't think he should resign
put your hand up now
if you don't think he should resign
three people there who don't think boris
johnson should resign so you can see
actually that's quite reflective
actually it almost i think that in some
ways uh does reflect the uh yugov pole
uh where about three fifths of people uh
said they thought he should resign to a
small majority well let's talk to stella
first shall we now stella uh you uh said
that you don't think boris johnson
should uh resign uh why is that stella
no i think um his leadership is
disappointing
um because we'd all like to see
men and women of integrity leading the
party and leading the country
but it's finding some someone to replace
him
so i'm not saying that he's the best
person for the job or that he should be
leading the country but i'm just saying
that i i failed to find anyone who could
take his place i think it's become
increasingly difficult to trust any
politicians
and
we begin to trust them and then we find
out they've done something abominable
and we lose our trust in them
so it does feel like reasoning
yeah it does feel perhaps that you're
losing your faith in all of them then uh
stella rather than just boris on his
lane thank good to talk to you there
i want to go all the way to our youngest
panelists now and that is tom tom horn
now what i'm interested to hear from you
tom is that november 2020 when some of
these parties were taking place you were
at university and you told one of our
researchers that on fridays
you found the police patrolling your
corridors of course on downing street
they were having what's known as wtf
fridays
wine time fridays so a bit different
perhaps from your own university
experience
yeah i think that's what's really made
me so angry about all of this is that we
literally you couldn't leave
your house your flat you can you know
people would go down to the supermarket
and come back and be asked what they
were doing why they were
why they were going shopping even if
they'd you know gone out for a bottle of
wine or just
for you know a takeaway for themself
because
none of us were allowed to mix and if
you were you were fined by the
university by the accommodation provider
and sometimes by the police as well and
yeah they did used to patrol the
corridors and i think maybe
if they'd have that in downing street
then maybe they would have been a bit
more disciplined
uh interesting stuff so tom not a
conservative voter you said that if you
were old enough you devoted green or lib
dems let's talk to rob tyler now because
you are a conservative voter aren't you
rob um what do you make of the uh report
well
i found it to be a little bit
wishy-washy to be honest uh there was
nothing new came out and
point three in the conclusions she says
that um many of the events shouldn't
have taken place which means that she
feels that some of the events were fine
to take place it'd be interesting rather
than seeing the mudslinging to find out
which ones were fine which ones were
okay yeah quite hard to imagine really
if you're looking back which ones would
have been allowed over the under the
rules but um interesting anyway let's
talk to you pradeep now shall we uh
pradeep sakhitaryan who is a labor voter
you're based in uh london um what did
you make of the report and do you think
the prime minister should resign
yeah i thought the report read like a
diary of a comprehensive uh set of
events but is very weak on consequences
and follow-up procedures and guidelines
should be that should be adhered in the
future
it felt like a slap on the wrist or for
the prime minister and a slap in the
face for the british public and i do
feel like the prime minister should
resign because leadership is
about integrity and also setting example
for the national policy and also
international policies we cannot have
our leaders uh state that they want to
steer world events and just be
hypocritical in national events so
what does that say about us on an
international stage so pretty pretty
critical there of uh the government uh
well let's bring in hannah shall we
hannah walker uh you voted labour at the
last election uh hannah and what do you
make of party game
i think we need to go slightly back a
square and remember that parties were
actually not allowed and disguising what
we all know our parties
as with with hindsight as work events
um
i i think is is muddying the waters and
i think to a certain extent we've
forgotten that we know we have intrinsic
values we have a sense of fairness
within us
and we look at those pictures and we
know
they were parties it doesn't matter what
you call them
they were parties they were parties you
say
yeah interesting to hear so you're
pretty actually scathing of what was
going on uh there as well and let's
bring in uh dr uh paul blom at this at
this point cause it's quite interesting
to hear from different reporters from
different parties but paul you're a
conservative
voter but it feels to me like you might
be losing a bit of faith with boris
johnson would that be right
yes i i certainly am i mean for me
in the report when it says there was a
lack of judgment and leadership i think
that's very telling
um
and
reflects badly on boris johnson
um and my concern actually with this
whole affair and i can understand people
getting very bored with it all is that
it's causing damage to our democracy and
our political system and pe and leading
to people to not engage with politics
which i think is very wrong and there
are lots of principled um politicians
but i think they're getting very bad
press from that element that's that's
causing uh all the control this
controversy yeah interesting to have and
uh
and i'd be interested to see you know
with the two by-elections coming up what
happens to the conservative mps whether
they're going to be putting in their
letters after the results of the book
i'd be seeing it could be seeing a bit
of a kicking in those bar election
results let's bring in lisa goddard at
shall we lisa
i know that you know you've had personal
experience of the sacrifices that many
people made
during uh kovid reasons i guess to be
angry
towards the passing in number 10 how are
you feeling
oh lisa i'm sorry i don't think we can
hear you right now
i'm gonna try and come back to you uh
oh
i am here if that's okay oh great you
are keep going sorry about that we lost
you momentarily the two things that
angered me today was uh
boris he repeatedly says they're going
to put their arms around people and the
fact that he felt it was appropriate in
his duty to say goodbye
i felt it my duty to say goodbye to my
best friend uh to my
uh uh elderly family friend that we have
she was taken into hospital she caught
covered in hospital we were not allowed
to see her we my mum got a phone call at
two a.m in the morning to say am's
passed away would you like to come and
see her
i would have liked to have seen her
before i would have liked to have had
time with my best friend before
he can't keep saying put your arms
around people it pains me every time i
hear it
and uh the fact that he just felt it his
duty to say goodbye i i just find it
offensive and and today i am angry and
it's not to do with partisan or being
labor supporter i would feel exactly the
same whoever was in the situation
whatever their political allegiance
thank you for sharing your story i think
it does it is really important to hear
from people like yourself who have you
know made those big sacrifices during
the pandemic not seeing people that the
closest to them and so we appreciate you
sharing that um let's have a very quick
uh thought uh to end uh shall we uh this
is vic daniels uh you're a conservative
supporter you're in london what did you
make of partygate and the report
um just quickly i suppose i should say
that i get while people are angry
everyone as you say has got a story um
but i think if you look at boris in his
career and especially the last five
months we didn't learn anything from the
sugar report we know he likes a drink we
know he likes a party we know there are
judgment issues integrity issues and
leadership issues but you have to look
at it as a package he's got a lot of
things right the eu he got he's got
right or he's got us in a position to
get it right the vaccine he got that
right this financial support package he
got a lot of that right and let's face
it he's having a fairly good war so i
think in the round uh my own personal
view as a conservative voter as someone
who voted for him in 2019 we now have to
draw a line on it and look at the big
macro issues that are going to impact
the most of the population okay thank
you very much and thank you uh for some
really strongly impre expressed
viewpoints uh today it was really
interesting to hear
everybody's uh take there well
lots of takes uh this evening lots of
strong feelings let's have a bit of a
post-match round up with our deputy
political editor uh
sam coates uh interesting from our panel
the majority at saying that boris
johnson should resign although some were
saying that actually it's time to draw a
line under the whole matter what does
the polling show well i think it shows
exactly that the panel is right and i
think what you can see here should boris
johnson resign following secrets report
this is a snap poll from yougov 59
say yes which the same
exactly but what i want to say about
this number is that i think whatever you
thought before sue gray's report
your mind hasn't been changed by what
you saw today you just think it more so
if you were crossed before your crosser
if you didn't care you thought the media
were going on about it you think that
even more because we're still going on
about it but do you think something's
going to happen let's look at the next
number
and this is about whether or not you
think uh uh uh well conservative voters
should now look at that this is very
nation only 27 so you've got 59 percent
of the voters as a whole 27
uh of um of those who vote conservative
now let's look uh about uh amongst those
who say uh that they think that boris
johnson will resign only seven percent
wow so even though a lot of people think
he should almost nobody think he will
and i think that's ultimately that's
probably the judgment tonight on the
basis of what you're seeing today
but sophie this isn't over not this is
in the party gate scandal i think
probably sue grace's report has drawn a
bit of a line under that but questions
about boris johnson his premiership well
there are just going to be so many more
why because the country is facing some
of the most difficult challenges with
the cost of living crisis with ukraine
all the things that your panel know
about uh only too well and tomorrow
we're going to get some answers some of
boris johnson and rishi sunax answers a
massive multi-billion pound statement
that we barely mentioned today we'll be
talking about tomorrow and that
will provide the key to whether or not
people have trust in boris johnson
having the biggest issues it's a very
good point isn't it and as you say we
haven't actually really mentioned uh the
big rabbit that's going to come out of
the hat tomorrow in the form of this
statement from
the chancellor uh rishi sunak but it
could be a game changer for boris
johnson at least that's what they hope
anyway sam thank you very much uh for
everything uh tonight uh busy uh
afternoon for you and another busy day i
think tomorrow too uh in the meantime
that is it uh from uh the take uh what a
day the long-awaited su grave report
finally published will it change
anything in a minute it feels like it
may be ticking along as it was before we
will be back next week and every week on
wednesdays at 9 00 pm next up it's sky
news at 10 thanks for watching see you
next week
[Music]